good evening everybody members offices
of the counselor members of the press
and public I welcome you to this meeting
of the council if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the officers via
the stairs either through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy square on the
green and officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber the Proceedings of this
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured and I
would urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present I can see at least one camera
but may I formally asked as anyone
intend to film the meeting thank you
very much any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of film being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the meeting would
everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress thank
you moving to agenda item number one
then apologies for absence we've
received apologies from councillor Ashby
and from councillor house are there any
other apologies please thank you counts
the game
dang
thank you very much gender item number
two concerning the minutes of the
previous meeting which was held on the
twelfth of may 2016 there is an
amendment I would like to draw members
attention to a typographical error in
the minutes at item 8b Council of
fairbrass should be referred to in that
item as the deputy leader of the council
not as the leader so subject subject to
that amendment I move that the minutes
of the meeting of this council held on
the fourteenth of July 2016 be approved
and signed as a correct record there a
second to please cancel a grower second
very much do members agree thank you
gender item number three announcements
I'm sure members would wish to join me
in welcoming councillor George mizuki
and counselor Linda Piper to this
meeting or to this council and I offer
you my congratulations on your recent
elections may I also take this
opportunity to introduce you to Charlie
Friedlander who has taken over from
Andrew Medlock and she is sitting here
in front of us having already exercised
her power with the gavel and the hammer
Charlie you're very welcome to this
council we look forward to working with
you and for members knowledge I Charlie
has been acting as my attendant and
driver on a fewer cases already
extremely professional woman and thank
you for coming to work with us agenda
item number four then declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest that need to be made thank you
gender item number five petitions to the
council 5a then is a petition containing
59
signatures which has been received by
this council and I am pleased to welcome
mr. Murray to the meetings to Murray
could you please make your way to the
top table thank you for coming mr.
Murray you have up to three minutes to
present your petition to the council
good I first thank you for seeing me for
this petition can you ask yourself a
question or a bus service bypasses two
villages on its way to a major city
locally the answer is no reason at all
let me fill you in with the reason for
the risk rest for a change the root of
the number nine ramsgate to canterbury
bus if you live in or near Minster or
mountain the only way to use this to use
this bus is to walk to the manor hut of
cliffs end or to Sal as the bus passes
along the dual carriageway bypassing
Minster a moncton I myself for most of
the residents of Moncton emminster make
the request for the route to change from
Canterbury the brass would leave the
main road and enter Moncton from the
roundabout at the top of willits hill
then along to Minster him Minster at the
corner of the new in public house it
would turn up tot Hill Street to the
roundabout on to the dual carriageway it
would then follow its original route to
Ramsgate it would reverse the roots on
its return to Canterbury the two said
villages access to cantabria ramsgate
the only existing way is on the number
11 route that goes through Preston and
wingham to Canterbury I think most would
agree a bit of around the houses route
the other way is that a train at a price
of 580 single or 69 to return that's
after nine o'clock in the morning a long
walk from Moncton as well the passing of
a secondary school at squires at Hurston
make an easy substitute for the other
schools infinite and the university and
making Canterbury shops excessive
accessible for older and younger alike
and also families without cars
and the possibilities of work for the
old and young alike I collected a fairly
decent percentage of the residence
signatures without trying too hard
especially the residence of the
smugglers leak caravan site as the bus
stop at the top of Tothill street would
I tell them a much needed bus route to
the said destinations after all is said
and done this is meant to be a bus
service but it doesn't seem to be
servicing the villages that it passes
just avoiding okay okay thank you very
much mr. Murray and in accordance with
the council's petition scheme this
petition will be referred to cabinet
without debate for report to the council
within three ordinary meeting's agenda
item 5b concerns a petition regarding
the condemnation of racism xenophobia
and hate crimes across thanet a petition
containing 340 valid signatures has been
received by this council and I am
pleased to welcome mr. right to the
meeting mr. right could you please make
your way to the top table thank you for
coming you have up to three minutes to
speak on this petition
the signatories of this petition ask
that you as a representative body of the
residents of planning reconsidered the
decision to not support amnesty
international's statement presented by
councillor iris johnston at the last
council meeting condemning racism
xenophobia and hate crimes across the
district hate crime is undeniably
increased in our communities in
conjunction with the EU votes the
figures released by the national police
chiefs council show that in the week
following the referendum vote the number
of incidents rose by fifty-eight percent
by the end of July it was at forty-nine
percent rise compared to the same point
in 2015 amnesty issued it in it stand
against hate campaign an urgent call on
all local councils to condemn hate and
commit to ensuring that all local bodies
and programs have the support and
resources needed to challenge it so far
thanet council is the only council in
the UK that has not supported the
campaign we believe this sends out a
poor message and a poor image of the
area it also appears to breach the
public duty public body equality GT to
be positively proactive in preventing
discrimination which more specifically
requires you have due regard to the
needs of foster good relations between
people who share a protected
characteristic and those who do not hate
crimes are acts of hostility by ignorant
and impressionable minds where the
perpetrators prejudice of a protected
group is the motivation such incidents
have included the beating to death of a
Polish man and the repeated kicking of a
Muslim mother to be in her stomach
causing her to lose her unborn twins
this is the real and tangible extremism
we have seen on our streets but these
acts don't take place in a vacuum they
are stimulated by strong and persistent
anti-migrant narrative in our media and
in our political parties it starts with
a single belief that someone of a
different race or religion is less
worthy or a threat the people affected
by this corrosive narrative are our
friends our colleagues there are people
feeling unwelcome when someone says oh I
didn't mean you following a flippant
comment made about migrants being a
burden to our community these are people
we work alongside every day
enriching our services friendship groups
and families and who contribute much
more than mere economic value paid in
taxes and they deserve to be treated
with the dignity and respect all human
beings should be treated with where have
we got to in the 21st century where
people of you would contempt is merely
objects of economic burden if we're to
truly change things we need to start
thinking and speaking of people as a
benefit and not a burden we call upon
Tanek district council to stand against
hate to state their opposition to race
in xenophobia and hate crimes ensure
resources and continued support are
available to do this and to affirm their
continuing intent for unity compassion
and understanding in order to ensure
safe for more cohesive communities for
all thank you thank you very much mr.
right Thank You mr. Wright in accordance
with the council's petition scheme the
petition will be referred to cabinet
without debate for report to the council
within three ordinary meeting's agenda
item number six questions from the press
and public there are no questions that
have been received from members of the
public in accordance with Council
Procedure rule number 13 gender item 7
questions from members of the council
would members now please refer to the
supplementary agenda number 12 questions
have been received from members of the
council in accordance with Council
Procedure rule 14 7a is a question in
relation to the toilets at minnis Bay
and I call upon councilor Ken Gregory
Thank You chairman Kuk councillor frame
please tell me when the public toilets
at Minnie's by our next you or scheduled
to be refurbished
cancel a brim to respond please Thank
You chairman the provision of public
toilets which is a non-statutory service
comes at an annual cost to the Council
of five hundred and twenty eight
thousand pounds of which 20,000 pounds
is is some allocated for fixtures and
fittings which is invariably used with
general maintenance as you can imagine
this son does not take long to spend
when considering that we currently have
32 at sets of toilets to maintain in
thanet the biggest single cost in the
current financial was the provision of
temporary toilets at Westbrook which
cost the authority 21,000 pounds this
was budgeted for separately on the same
basis as a similar provision the
preceding year it is the intention of
the council to undertake a review of the
provision of toilets in conjunction with
the review of corporate assets and the
asset management plan until this process
concludes no major works will be taken
place on toilets as such and in
answering this specific question there
are currently no plans to refurbish the
toilets at minister bay at this points
Thank You councillor Gregory do you have
a supplementary question in that case
counselor brim I wonder if you could
answer me this in birchington in El Faro
car park we have a set of toilets have
been shut for most of the summer for
some reason or other I noticed the
gentleman side has been open in recent
days but what has resulted because there
are no there be no signs around the
village to say they're shut people have
been rushing around there to go to the
toilet and been unable to do so and
therefore have been urinating in public
and worse in public and recently females
have had to be using the gentleman's
toilets and check that there's no one in
there before they go because the ladies
were still shut was the consideration of
having portable or temporary toilets on
the carpark taken into account
Thank You brim please Thank You mr.
chairman like the toilet sooner
birchington haven't been shut for most
of the summer and they have there is a
leak and we are working on it we're
currently we were trying to establish
where the leak was from where the
stopcock is which is located on the
corner of one stool court and I think
it's just less than a hundred yards from
that point we've had a cat and Jenny
equipment out there and I've been on
site while they've been cattin Jenning
it they've dug up part of the road to
make some minor observations now we
intend to put a stop [ __ ] which we've
paid southern water and we're waiting
for Clancy dhokra to actually they've
got a 21 day turnaround and then a week
and that's what we're dealing with we're
dealing with agencies that just don't
get things done at the drop of a hat but
we are on it and those toilets will be
opened in the meantime we're saying to
general public that the library have
said that they are when they're open
residents of birchington and can use the
toilets in the library thank you
Thank You councillor brim and councillor
Gregory agenda item 7b then is a
question in relation to the royal sands
development and I call upon councillor
savage please Thank You chairman on the
20th July 2016 planet district council
received 3 million pounds from kardi
Rams gates for the freehold of the site
of the royal sands project with the
subsequent changes to the directorship
of that company can he provide us with
an update that can satisfy concerns for
the completion of the project within the
time span agreed thank you Karen thank
you i call upon the leader to respond
please thank you cancer surge neither
the change in the directors of cloudy
ramsgate limited nor the subsequent
change in the name of the company to
Ramsgate development come in limited
makes any difference to the
enforceability of the legal obligation
set out in agreements made originally
with Carly ramsgate limited this
includes the option agreement which
gives the council the right to buy back
property if the development does not
reach specified milestones within the
agreed timeframe Thank You councillor
savage do you have a supplementary well
of course I do against this does he feel
it would be prudent for the council to
ring friend ring-fence the three million
pounds covered to necessary to cover the
necessity to repossess the site if it
becomes necessary thank you leader
please yeah I was down in ramsgate on
Wednesday night and I promised to go
down and talk to community groups around
what the situation was a pleasure armor
and interest enough this was one of the
questions that came up and I would have
to say that the residents were Browns
back over there some had one view
somehow some wanted ring-fenced others
wanted what was there to be spent to be
spent to other projects so that even if
that SAT still undeveloped for a while
other things were able to float and move
forward up until going on Wednesday
night I always said that we would
ring fence that money for spending on
products in ramsgate if there is a big
call in ramsgate to hold on to it in the
hope of maybe needing to buy it back we
will look at that again but right now i
would say that we will probably stick
with looking projects and ramsgate says
some good news to come out what's
happened there perhaps the first time in
many many years agenda item number 8
motions on notice please note that no
motions on notice have been received in
accordance with council procedure rule 3
gender item number 9 then is the leaders
report I call upon the leader thank you
as the administration here in planets
and did so recently I'm often asked what
our purpose would be particularly post
June the 23rd seems to be a popular
question amongst media commentators and
others and I suppose my my answer is
twofold once-daily Briggs it and the
other to do with the circumstances here
and that our purpose here has to be too
different from the labour and Tory
administration's that have gone before
us whose persistent combined messes we
keep having to clear up this segment
relates very closely to the first three
items on the leaders report this evening
where my role to date and indeed the
capital shoulder dangers generally
simply being to feel the hospital past
given to us by previous administrations
there can be little doubt to return to
cancer savages question from a different
direction that the pleasure armor saga
of the seafront in ramsgate is one of
the most shiny examples are politically
inept issued undertaken by a variety of
administration is going back to the
mid-1990s Cancellara's johnson in spite
of her poor record decision-making in
this council is still a member of this
chamber as deputy leader in the earlier
years of this century she oversaw a
prospectus for this development hort
around potential investors in the city
of london which included the sale of the
freehold from day one and then spent 13
years denying her intention until in
2015 she achieved her aim with proud
newspaper
photographs the margate counselor who
sold ramsgate seafront sold it proudly
just two months before the election
deservedly throughout her toxic and
dysfunctional administration on its ear
not all smiles because Castle abatement
had a little bit bayford a living
involvement all this as well as the man
who oversaw the negotiations that are
bitted to put a stop date on the
development contract creating chaos
around sensible negotiation of this for
some years and that should also be noted
as I said here in silent our main
purpose has to be to be different from
labour and Tory who's persistent
combined mrs. we keep having to clear up
cuz then we move on to Dreamland
compulsory purchased in 2011 under
councillor Bayford we're fighting the
battle and compensation to this day and
you'll see some of it spilled over into
the public arena just in the last week
or two handed on by councillors Johnston
heart screw to a clearly
undercapitalized operator whose vision
understanding of what drives alleged
versus seemed to be somewhat
short-sighted nearly as inept as the
contract negotiator by labor on behalf
of residence the end result is a twice
insolvent operator in just over a year
here insanity our purpose has to be
different from labour and Tory who's
persistent messes we keep having to
clear up then there's a local plan an
evidence-based document which officially
began in 2011 but is still not complete
the council must produce these plans
Givens planning inspectors there's a
good cause for our land use decisions
currently the Manston Airport site is
purely reserved for aviation but the
airport has been closed for two years
and we needed to show evidence to
maintain that in any emerging plan we
could stick with the aviation use only
this was the background to the
commissioning of report on airport
viability by specialist consultancy
avior avi met with both river oak and
Soulja gale to understand their view of
the sustainability of freight hub
operations at manston yet still
concluded the airport operations at
monster
are very unlikely financially viable in
the longer term river oak have now had
four chances to impress they failed as
an indemnity partner in 2014 they failed
as an indemnity partner in 2015 they
failed to take advantage of a city
financier who was seeking to invest 150
million pounds and have never failed to
demonstrate their case to a view as well
I am saddened for the campaigners who's
battled to maintain their dream of an
airport has been both valiant and brave
Manson has an important heritage that
any future for the airport has to be
evidence with real numbers something
river oak have signally failed to
produce to date any mixed use
designation does not exclude aviation
use so river oak need to pull some
serious evidence out of the bag in the
coming weeks to demonstrate the
potential for a working airport two
rounds of soft market testing reports on
viability the lack of interest from
recognized players in the aviation
market place all demand answer so it
really is time for a director show
whether they can or come out to produce
a serious business case for an airport
otherwise in the words of Tory
Chancellor Philip Hammond only a few
days ago when times change we must
change with them balancing the books any
council is a challenge a lethal
combination of growing demand or
starrett e cuts and rising costs makes
producing the legally required balanced
budget tough in planet attacks made
harder by some of these decisions that
we have inherited as indicated in common
with many councils who look to see if
there are any assets it would be
advantageous to sell to fund our capital
program the building and improvement
works our area so desperately needs
today and we held an extraordinary
cabinet to an initial tranche of
possible asset disposals which then
undertook a three-week public
consultation before they return to
cabinet for decision the collective
rationale for this list is that
virtually all of them are either
currently leased or had inquiries the
leases transfers community or other uses
and therefore we know that there is some
market possibility for different
ownership so far so good one might think
identify some unused or
use assets to fund other works normal
business for any landowner with cash
flow to manage by funding capital
expenditure and reducing maintenance
costs at the same time went into the
picture shows a gentleman called Craig
McKinley using House of Commons
notepaper taxpayer-funded postage and
envelopes stokke an image of fire sale
supported by his own invented numbers of
350 flats at jaws by in a sweep of
hubris that would shame Pinocchio's nose
our local MP has simply demonstrate his
inability to understand genuine public
consultation rather attends that people
have been used to before if we had
really wanted to make building use of
these sites then logic says maximize the
value by getting planning permission
before sale which of course has not
happened because that is not the purpose
of the consultation which genuinely
seeks public views if at the end of the
consultation the view is that we should
do everything we can to protect the
green wedge and farmland then that is
fine such an opinion also inform future
sites which may be considered if so then
the question is whether it's cell with
covenants which may mean no sale at all
if the value becomes less in the
agricultural lease rental and we move
all in reports the council we have to
make all the options clear and
particularly if we are going to take an
option which is a less than the greater
cash return of development land we have
to show into the localism ACT that
residents understand that is what we are
doing on their behalf because here in
thanet our purpose must be different
from that of labour and the Tories whose
persistent goodbye mrs. we keep having
to clear up I would like to have updated
you on the thames st proposals and the
five council merger but sadly i've run
out of time the brits a great extension
worthy of update but we all heard at
last meeting how important the
constitutional deadline is two other
party leaders and that only happened
this week most interesting of all just
yesterday two of the stalwarts of Old
Party politics here in this chamber one
labour one Tory Don's ceremonial robes
of office to prance around all Stan Park
abusing their ceremonial positions to in
pursuit of political campaigning one of
whom will apparently go to any lengths
to protect any asset in margate but
devoted many years of their life to
selling ramsgate seafront down the
swanee that's old politics politics
which denigrates all our reputations in
this chamber but of course I can't tell
you about it because it happened only
yesterday and the other group leaders
could not be given the requisite five
days notice which one of these
perpetrators yesterday so strongly
advocated as a change to our
Constitution the same woman who decried
independent members assisting our
council because she could not bear to
hear them tell the truth in the
constitution of this council the
reputation of this council the
decision-making of this council the
legacy of this council our job is to be
different from labor and the Tories
whose persistent complain messes we are
still having to clear up
thank you very much counselor wells I
call upon counselor Bayford to comment
on or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report yeah Thank You chairman I
think that that speech was quite
astonishing really it wasn't that long
ago that this council achieved notoriety
for being a fairly unpleasant chamber
and I thought that we'd reached an
accord that there would be some attempt
at some kind of harmony some cross-party
working what we just heard is absolutely
disgraceful it's put this council about
such a long way and I'm a funny
incredible the council of worlds can use
the word hubris about other people his
arrogance and hubris knows absolutely no
bounds whatsoever I have to say that
when he was in our administration which
he conveniently forgets he was part of
the collective responsibilities for the
decisions that he's now rubbishing so I
don't know work the definition of
hypocrisy is but I think that could be
there somewhere the other thing is that
I've gotta say that when he was a member
of our group I think a less likely you
kick person I go a long way to see what
you've got there is a carpetbagger who
cross the floor purely for his own
personal gain and nothing else what he
also does a TV and forgets the loyalty
of those people that stood by him when
we had the situation of having a cabinet
member that couldn't attend council
meetings because he was in arrears with
his council tax and then he talks about
his fine actually competence how on
earth can he do this it's just stunning
I'm glad that he didn't mention the
airport though glad that he did that
because you're elected almost solely on
the promise of planes flying again from
menston but for over a year now
everybody's noticed that you've gone a
bit call on the idea now these quite
sure why but you have but you've also
rushed to embrace the IV report with
remarkable alacrity but the facts are
that a report commissioned about two
years ago by this council
actually concluded that it could be
viable to run an airport of Manston
provided there was somebody prepared to
invest significant capital sounds well
I've got news for you counselor world's
there is somebody it's river oak they
are prepared to do that they weren't
prepared to show the detailed plan to
your consultants and I can understand
that because a confidential commercial
or commercial confidentiality but the
fact is that they've carried on mobile
apps were no help from this council
they're seeking to put an airport back
there they're pursuing a dco and despite
your election pledge you've never once
given any any effort to support their
effort not shown any support whatsoever
I was at presentation by one of the
Oviatt consultants where he stated that
experts who predicted a significant
increase in air freight demand in the UK
based their propositions on a hypothesis
that he didn't accept now that tells me
that had TDC picks a different
consultant they might have got a
different result they might have got a
consultant they said it could be viable
as the 12 years ago did I've got to tell
you that my group believes that the
dream of Manston being operational again
still lives I believe that there are
many others in this chamber that share
that dream and I hope when the time
comes they're brave enough to stand up
and get counted you can't play fast and
loose with the electorate councillor
world you made a promise you've no
intention of keeping we're either
promise we're sticking by thank you
please okay thank you the election is
the election and yes you're quite right
there was a promise made certainly do
something within seven days to actually
put the CP 0 in progress and that was
done on the very first night that we
took office and I went along with other
colleagues advil way to give river oak a
second chance to present the case that
they may actually put together and they
failed abysmally on the process of
proving that they had the ability to put
the funds in place to be an addendum
partner and the truth is and the Demi's
port now only has one purpose and that's
to provide the money and the one thing
they could not do was get anywhere
beyond proving that they could lay hands
on more than two million pounds and in
that circumstance they were given a
second chance and shortly afterwards a
third chance and now a fourth chance and
I hope that your optimism proof root for
that on the fifth chance when they
operate the DC area government where the
ability to actually provide proof is
that a higher level than those that they
failed already that they come out on top
because actually you're right many of us
would like to see an airport at manston
but I can't build a local plan on a
dream we have to build it on evidence
and if river oak can't produce the
evidence we can't back river oak it's as
simple as that
call upon counselor matter face to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report Thank You chair
well over on this side the back row here
we didn't make promises all we promised
with God to the airport that we would
work with the current owners for the
best result for thanet so let's put that
one to bed right firstly pleasure armor
the meeting you held you had last week
at Ramsgate at Town Council the Labour
group welcomes your clear commitment to
spending the receipts from pleasure
armor in and for ramsgate projects that
has been very well received dreamland
2010 the CP 0 process started and my
understanding cancel the whales is that
you were part of the conservative
cabinet at that time I'd also like to
remind you that it was a you Kip cabinet
that signed off on the lease to the
current lessys at dreamland but I am
concerned about the dreamland project
because the labor group representative
on overview and scrutiny is still
waiting for the scrutiny committee to be
able to scrutinize the dreamland project
and they are still waiting for the audit
report to do so in the Constitution it
states when fide members from at least
two parties asked for a report to come
to scrutinize I'd like to ask why this
is not yet happening on the local plan
we have a briefing members briefing on
Tuesday and hopefully we will be able to
hear when this plan is going to be
finally put to bed because there is some
concern among residents but the fact the
housing numbers that were being given
appear to be keep to keep rising I
understand it's gone up by another
thousand recently and I also like to
remind him that the local plan was
possibly delayed by a change of
government so hopefully we can speed
that up a little bit then we'll all know
where we are and the asset disposal and
I understand from speaking to some
tenants they knew absolutely nothing
about fact that where they were making a
living was on an asset disposal list so
could i please ask that in future when
this comes to an extraordinary cabinet
that any tenant
who is going to be affected at least has
to have the courtesy of telling them
this and also could be have a bit more
notice of the extraordinary cabinet
meeting because I had a holiday booked
when you arrange that meeting and I have
been lambasted by a number of people the
fact that I wasn't present to speak on
behalf of anybody who was involved with
any of the assets that were planned but
I do have some concern there's an awful
lot of assets still to go and if they're
only going to be 22 at a time each going
out to consultation could ask how many
consultations you anticipate having
because it seems to be an awful lot to
go through if it's 22 for one meeting
and then another 22 or do you anticipate
the process will speed up and you did
send when you sent out your list of
subjects about the kingdom enforcement
contract but I don't think you got to
that so if I can ask you a question is
there any chance of this contract coming
back in-house and as a supplementary to
that could ask how much it actually
costs lanik District Council to have
people finding the public for EM
dropping a cigarette 80 pounds of time
and all last time when we had a little
bit debate about whether or not we
should have got the information from you
in advance rather than the tuesday
evening i did say that the open-top bus
service was starting for the summer
holidays and i'm very pleased as a
member of the thanet the bus partnership
groups say that 15,000 fare-paying
passengers were carried during the
six-week period there were a few
problems with inconsiderate parking but
our parking manager was on the case and
next year because George Hill Road will
be back open the bus will go from Margot
station to the paddling pool at the far
end of ramsgate so it will be a fully
full journey thank you thank you very
much I call upon the leader to respond
please and thank you I think the key the
key point I think you're making their
zoo is speeding up the process or
whatever we have something like 600
in total is no intention to I get
through all six hundred this year that
the target is a hundred seven that looks
like for lists in the course the next
few months which will give us time for
the same level of consultation on each
of those lists in order to actually get
through and see where we get to at the
end of the financial year at the yeah
can you are feeling I know who you're
talking about and if you've got yeah I
do and he did no actually because I I
personally told him when he was when we
were on a little trip to the psalm of
the week to before so I find that
interesting and maybe we'll talk about
after that's okay okay all right thank
you
just leave it
thank you I call upon counselor Eleanor
to comment on or ask questions in
relation to the leaders report in the
absence of councillor Ashby thank you
Jim I wasn't expecting this but at the
moment I'm rather short of troops I will
I've listened carefully to leaders
speech and I will pass the synopsis
orbit to my non-existent other members
I'm in a very unfortunate position at
the moment because as you all know in
the political life God is on the side of
the big battalions is not on my side at
the moment thank you
thank you thank you for your kind
thoughts thank you very much counselor
Wells it goes towards the behavior
within the chamber if we do remember to
be respectful of everybody and at this
point i'll pick up on a comment from
councillor Bayford we do not wish to go
back to the earlier days of so but we
don't wish to go back there so I call
upon capsule of growth priests to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report well thank you
very much chairman I am in the fortunate
position to have one more in my army
tonight but I think there's enough being
said around the table and it's nice to
see a little bit of banter going
backwards and forwards between the two
leaders so that's about all i have to
say thank you thank you
thank you agenda item no I'm sorry you
can't no I'm sorry you can't agenda item
number 10 no no I'm sorry I think you
need to sit down counselor Johnson I am
standing you need to sit I'm sorry I'm
standing you need to sit or I will ask
them to remove you please sit thank you
we do not wish to go back to where the
council love nope it is not agenda item
number 10 the report of the chairman of
overview and scrutiny panel I call upon
councillor d Saunders to present his
report Thank You chairman members the
report that you find in your agenda pack
this evening outlines the activities of
the overview and scrutiny panel and the
working part is since we last met in
July as you will see counselor Honda
stemmer mersing attended the panel
meeting on the sixteenth of august and
gave an informative presentation on the
cabinet's view of the new economic
development strategy for thanet and at
the same meeting the panel were given
the opportunity of reviewing and
commenting on the new events policy and
procedures as part of the overall
engagement and awareness process I have
to say that that was very interesting
and some useful comments were made by
the panel which members would appreciate
particularly those members who are
involved in organizing an event for our
district members in June the Community
Safety Partnership working party agreed
a work program which as you'll see in
2.2 on page 19 lists five key topics on
which to focus their scrutiny efforts in
this connection acting Detective Chief
Inspector max Dave
from kentley sexual investigation team
together with Chief Inspector Sharon
Adly attended the meeting on the third
of all October to answer questions and
address which indeed they did members
concerns relative to the number of
recorded sexual offenses the resulting
convictions and the support services
that are available to victims with
insanity the working party will pursue
that because there's some more
information that they require and
hopefully once we have all the
information together it will make a
worthwhile members briefing so that all
members are aware exactly what the
situation is as I said it was a very
informative meeting and I would urge and
encourage members to note future agenda
topics and to take the opportunity of
attending such working party meetings
they tend not to be just talking shop
and are those who attended Cal surfing a
brass and councillor Johnson found it
very educational and very informative
and it would be useful to see more
member there taking note of exactly the
work that the scrutiny working party is
do members following on from the peer
review and for a trial period overview
and scrutiny have introduced public
speaking and its meetings and in
addition I would also confirm that in
conjunction with democratic services we
are considering recommendations to adopt
a new scrutiny approach which we hope
will enable the panel to plan and
conduct their work more effect
efficiently and add value to the
decision-making process at the moment
this is currently a work in progress and
I hopeful that I'll be able to report in
more detail at a future meeting Thank
You members I commend this report thank
you
Thank You counsel soldiers agenda item
number 11 the annual treasury management
review 2015 2016 I call upon councillor
townand Thank You chairman the annual
treasury management review 2015 16 this
report summarizes the treasury
management activity the 2015 260 it was
approved by governance and Audit
Committee on the twenty-second of June
and cabinet on the twenty-eighth of July
it is a backward look at the past
financial year and sets out the interest
paid on borrowing and earned on
investments as explained in capitals
review in section 2 of the report 2015
16 continued with the very low interest
environment although it is too early to
fully anticipate the longer term impact
of breakfast on interest rates current
commentators suggest that rates won't be
rising significant significantly anytime
soon I move that cabinet approves the
recommendations as set out Thank You
councillor town in jessore a second to
please Thank You counselors thomas
merton members agree thank you agenda
item number 12 changes to committees
panels and boards for 2016 2017 will
subject of proportionality I call upon
the leader to make a proposal in respect
of the options as outlined in the report
and proposed option 1 mr. chairman
option one thank you very much is there
a seconder Thank You counsel in
fairbrass there's any member wish to
propose an alternative option councillor
bayford fees option to chairman option
two so we have any further options
recommendations so needed my secondary I
bigger part in the secondary thank you
very much councillor Savage okay I would
like then please to request a show of
hands in favor of option one
do we have the fifty percent
against other people's options option to
thank you those in favor of option two
please
are there any abstentions having
achieved more than 50 thank you very
much option one is carried nomination of
members to serve on committees group
leaders may take this opportunity to
advise of their nominations to
committees panels and boards for the
remainder of 2016 17 or alternatively
advise democratic services after this
meeting I call upon the leader ok I
believe option 1 requires me to nominate
additional seats on each the cavity so
councillor collar for the planning
committee councillor how's the licensing
board cancer is a key for the everyone
scrutiny panel councillor Linda Piper
for governance an audit council Linda
pipe of the general purposes can select
program for the boundary electro agents
working party cancer as icky for the
Constitution review working party and
councillor program for the joint
transportation board thank you
Thank You councillor Bayford you wish to
make any changes Thank You councillor
matter face do you wish to make a
decision Thank You counselor Eleanor in
the absence of counsel Ashby no changes
sir thank you cancel a Grove thank you
agenda item number 30 yes cancel a
question here to have forgotten the JTB
which was a separate table on the agenda
for this item can I call upon the leader
to suggest his option
boy take counsel the world's for clarity
for the members it's on page 45 at the
top of the page 41 aho
oh my coffee it's 45
can you advise your waist page 45 not
page 41 hello is on pace for as you want
option toy don't you page 41 outlines
the yes yes the table on option one is
the proportionality calculations you're
quite right the the table 5 and in the
second line in the table should read
option two you're quite right yes yes
yes but the what though the implications
of those options are is explained at the
top of page 45 at paragraph four point
seven three or four point seven five
depending on whether you want option one
or option two yeah so they call on yep
calling the leader to say would you like
the world's leading option one option to
officer wanting
are there any other options being
offered you say that game because I'm
not some people listening are there any
other options to be offered apart from
the leaders recommendation for option
one
cancel Cobra thank you we're done yeah
okay thank you very much now I think we
can move to agenda item number 13 the
standards hearing decision and I call
upon mr. how's the council's monitoring
officer Thank You chairman yes you have
a report item 13 about a recommendation
from a standard hearing subcommittee and
they recommended a number of sanctions
in research council Larkins and two of
those sanctions are here tonight one
relates about receiving a public apology
we should be read out of the meeting and
the second relates to a former sensor
which is the issue of anna photo of
unfavorable opinion or judgment or
reprimand now you aren't here to
consider the decision itself merely the
recommended sanctions I think it's
important to say it should be a fairly
binary decision whether you do or don't
accept each individual sanction and it's
recommend we take them in turn and that
suggests what remember think is if there
is a debate the debate cannot be about
the decision it can only be about the
sanctions thank you thank you mr. house
I therefore propose that i as chairman
of the council readout councillor
Larkins apology which is to be published
in the minutes of this meeting is there
a second to please cancel the Grove
thank you the members agree
thank you I will now read out the
apology from councillor Larkins I wish
to offer an unreserved apology for any
offence caused by the recent comment
made by a Facebook account I acknowledge
this is not party policy and realized
the comment risked blaming a whole
religion for the activities of the few i
call upon mr. house the council's
monitoring officer Thank You Joan again
moving to the second recommendation
which is about sent to encounter Larkins
again just to be clear this is about
whether the council does or does not
adopt that particular sanction it's not
about the decision itself which you've
delegated to the standards committee to
deal with Thank You Jeremy thank you I
now propose at the council sensuous
councillor Larkins for bringing her role
as councillor into disrepute with the
leader please second second mr. shin
thank you Jim members agree thank you
that concludes the business for the
meeting of this council thank you for
everybody for your attendance